Speaker 1: All sorts of different right wing
media types on the Internet have increasingly
been talking about a civil war, a civil war
that they believe is coming and in some sense
a civil war that some of them seem to actually
be welcoming.
And whether it is because of those individuals
or for other reasons.
We now have two in five Americans, roughly
40% of Americans who believe that within the
next decade there is going to be another civil
war here in the United States.
Now, when we say civil war and United States,
what we think back to is the Civil War in
the United States, of course, in the 19th
century, which was a war essentially over
slavery, it was between the Union and the
Confederacy, the union which wanted to end
slavery and the Confederacy which wanted to
keep it.
Now, there's been revisionist history which
has been done to sort of glorify the Confederacy
or at least make it seem more benign.
And usually the way that's done is they say
it's not about a war to keep slavery.
It's a war for states rights, a fundamental
conservative value.
And sure, if what the states wanted a right
to do was to keep slavery illegal, then so
be it.
But really, it wasn't about slavery.
It was about states.
Right now that's B.S.
doesn't we don't have to get into more detail,
but that is the the false story that many
of those who I guess today would still be
on the side of the Confederacy.
Like that's the story they like to tell about
the first civil war.
And now we have an Economist YouGov poll wherein
40% of Americans believe we are heading towards
another civil war.
Now, let's look at a couple of the different
things that are in this poll.
First and foremost, do Americans expect political
divisions and violence to increase over the
next few years?
And the answer is that on political divisions,
two thirds of Americans believe we will be
more politically divided, and that political
division is likely to increase.
And on political violence, 65% believe that
political violence has increased.
And looking ahead, 62% believe it will continue
to increase.
Now, what is the partizan split here?
This is very, very important for those who
say that in the last year and a half, the
country has become more divided.
Republicans are more likely than independents
and Democrats to say that.
Now, what has happened during that time?
Well, a Democrat, Joe Biden, became president
of the United States.
The mere presence of Biden, they believe,
has made the country more divided.
And if you look at looking ahead, do you think
the amount of political division is more likely
to increase, stay the same or decrease?
It is Republicans more than Democrats that
believe political division will increase,
but it's not a big difference.
This is actually quite interesting because
it's only a 14 point split.
The country is mostly on the same page, both
Republicans and Democrats.
58% of Democrats think there will be more
political division and 72% of Republicans.
It is a difference, but it is not a dramatic
partizan difference.
Now, on the issue of civil war, this is very,
very important and disturbing.
Take a look at these numbers.
Among adult citizens in general, 43% say it
is very or somewhat likely that there will
be another civil war in the next ten years.
And this is where the partizan split is somewhat
more significant.
Among Democrats, those, for example, who are
strong Democrats.
40% believe a civil war is very or somewhat
likely, whereas among strong Republicans,
54% believe a civil war is very or somewhat
likely.
That is a significant difference.
But also, it's not like the 7020 type thing.
You know, you there are questions you can
ask people and the partizan split is significantly
more dramatic.
I'm struggling to think of which ones they
would be, but on issues related to, for example,
guns, sometimes you see a massive partizan
split.
14 points on civil war is not like a dramatic
Now, where I believe you would see a significant
difference would be if you ask folks, what
do you believe would cause such a civil war?
What do you believe would cause such a civil
war?
My instinct is and this is something that
you would have to do a poll on.
If you ask the left wingers, what do you think
would cause the Civil War?
I think most left wingers would say right
wingers launching a civil war.
And if you asked the right wingers what would
cause a civil war, I think they would mostly
say the left wingers would cause a civil war.
In other words, I think in different terms
you would see both the left and the right
say that it would be the right that would
precipitate and take action on that civil
war.
The leftists would say the right wingers are
going to do it because they don't like the
ways in which society is changing.
And the right wingers would say, we had no
choice because look what the leftists were
doing to our country.
Very different moral frameworks in terms of
who is responsible.
But I think it would be, in a sense, an agreement
in that it would be the rightists who actually
launch it.
And the rightist would say, well, we had no
choice because of what the leftists have done
to this country.
Not particularly pleasing numbers.
I mean, when nearly half the country thinks
in the next decade there will be a civil war.
It doesn't seem to be boding particularly
well.
We're going to follow these numbers and it
would be good to have other polling as well,
because it is increasingly a topic.
I mean, later in the show, actually, we're
going to have a clip of conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones who just got dinged for 49 million
in a defamation suit.
He seems to be trying to precipitate that
civil war and is predicting it.
I think within the I think he said in 71 days,
oddly specific.
But we'll get to that Alex Jones clip a little
bit later on
in
the show.